foreign
let's go back to Salt Lake City and talk
to Megan what's up Megan
hi Dr John wow it's way better that's
fantastic that's awesome
what's up kid
um so I have recently failed myself my
spouse my marriage by
um committing Financial infidelity for
the third time
and I feel like I have really just
a broken my husband into pieces and
I I recognize that this is completely my
fault and
It's A coping mechanism that I use when
I'm in distress and I
I just really need to figure out how to
how to best help the situation and get
trust again and and work towards a
better future because he's
been um forgiving enough to give me
another chance even though I don't
really deserve that I feel do you
believe that
um
or is that just like a thing you say
so hurtful
um it's like he even expressed me it's
like being actually cheated on yeah um
yeah the the conversations I've had with
folks behind closed doors it's very very
similar
just the devastation of it all how bad
how bad is your um how bad has it been
um
two times
uh we um paid those off together and and
got debt free and then
um I was doing really well I was
following a budget and and doing other
things to help manage stress and
um other things that were going on
in my life we've had a rough couple of
years
um these last two years because
um several people in my family passed
away
including my mom oh geez I'm sorry yeah
and um so I was doing
in my opinion really well and um I
didn't know
that um I had some health issues
creeping up and had to go off of work
for about 12 weeks just because I was in
a lot of pain and constant headaches and
a lot of a lot of problems
um relating to that and didn't work and
I didn't know that my credit card
attached to my bank
was still active and so I was
overdrafting on certain things and just
bills and didn't know that that was
coming out of the credit card so that's
kind of what started it all
and I didn't want to come clean about
that because it's embarrassing I just
wasn't paying attention and then it
became a free-for-all
yeah
so let me ask you
um
because even I bet your headaches and
autoimmune
are stemming from
somewhat possibly the same places
I do know that they um I had a brain
scan and they have two brain tumors oh
you do okay all right yeah so what kind
of tumors are they
um one is a pituitary adenoma and the
other one is a pineocytoma I'm waiting
to get that one evaluated but the
pituitary is the nine okay
and what was the other one uh opinions
by the pineal gland yeah yeah
um
I I would have to sit down and look at
the architecture of where these things a
lot of questions here one of the
questions off the top off the top of my
head like just so
with with that piece of insight
um
it may be that you've got just some
behavioral regulation challenges because
of
like a legitimate brain disorder you've
got stuff going on in your mind you've
got tumors in your head right and so
um
it might be that you've need a healthy
dose of Grace for yourself and some high
restriction just some big time
roadblocks right similar to like
when my granddad became 85 like he
couldn't drive anymore
and he's not a bad guy but he was going
to run somebody over so he couldn't
drive anymore so
um it had nothing to do with character
had nothing to do with it just like I
can't have debit card anymore I can't
have a credit card we can't have it I
can't have access to the bank account
because I've got tumors on my brain that
have some sort of uh relationship too
Behavior regulation that's that's a
thing that could be it
another question I'd have for you is
not knowing that
I would be willing to bet that somebody
at some point you have a major major in
your bones problem with authority
yeah where does that come from
parents being really
were they insanely strict
um I think most of the problem was being
compared uh to my
older sister who has some ADHD and and
like behavior and not Behavior learning
problems and being told that I was kind
of wasting my potential and
um every time I would like mess up
I would get lectured or privileges taken
away or so so let's let's back out a
little bit lectures happen that's part
of life privilege is getting taken away
that's part of life yeah if you can
honestly look back at your
upbringing
and
interactions with Mom and Dad
interactions with brothers and sisters
relationships were contingent on
performance
and when you didn't perform
well then you can't go on the family
whatever or we're all going to the movie
and you got to stay at home
or we're gonna do this thing and you
have to eat outside whatever
it becomes this
to be in here you've got to dance monkey
dance
see what I'm saying and so that behavior
can get transferred to something as
simple as a budget I'm not doing what
you say
I'm not
I can do whatever I freaking want to
because I'm an adult
yeah and when you the way you're
describing like I'm trying to be good
I'm trying to be good I'm trying to be
good you're not changing your core
identity there you're trying to White
Knuckle this thing as tough as you can
and you're gonna fail every time
I'm not having candy I'm not having
candy I'm not eating junk food I'm not
filling the blank yes I am because I
haven't dealt with the core issues
so let's take let's take
um
let's take brain tumors off the table
for a second holding that might be part
of the problem okay might be a
significant part of the problem
what if you were able to see a budget as
one of the greatest gifts you could give
to yourself
or let me say it this way my friend Sal
um I've had him on the show several
times he's uh talks about
um diet and exercise with on his show on
the Mind pump show
um he says you can't hate your body
into shape
you can't hate the way you look so bad
and that's why you go to the gym because
then the gym becomes punishment
and you can only punish yourself for so
long before you end up at the buffet
again
you can only punish and hate yourself so
long before I'm just not going to the
gym anymore because it's a literal
beating like literally it's a punishment
when I open my eyes and think I love
myself so much I'm gonna go give myself
an hour
of movement exercise doing hard stuff
I'm gonna I give myself an hour that's
how much I love myself
dude my gym time goes an hour and 20
minutes goes an hour I gotta literally
leave my son came down this morning it
was like Dad we gotta go
because I was I was I was giving myself
this gift it wasn't a matter of I gotta
go get it done and I don't always do
that but most of the times it's a gift
right so
it's a matter of changing your
perspective from this budget is
something that constrains me doesn't
treat me like an adult tells me I'm
stupid cuts me off from relationship
just like my I grew up
always it's a comparison thing because
if we had this and the neighbors have
that and they have this and the Joneses
have that
instead of then do your budget's the
greatest gift because your budget's
gonna help you build wealth over the
long term it's gonna keep you safe in
the present and you see what I'm saying
it's just a total refrain
yeah
and then having like sitting down with
your husband once a week to talk about
where we are financially becomes a gift
you give to yourself
huh
or it becomes a more powerful gift than
another pair of shoes or another
whatever thing it is that you're buying
right yeah that would be nice
have you tried that before
um we actually had a meeting a budget
meeting last night but we've both kind
of been sick so it wasn't super
productive but we plan to do it going
forward can you make those fun
sure here's what I mean
I'm thinking of
um there's families out there so I'm
about to make this weird sorry guys like
strip budget or
um silly budget or joke budget is there
a way to keep it from becoming another
business meeting in the house but we're
gonna have a blast
we're gonna be silly and we're gonna
make it fun and it's a competition who
saves whoever saves the most gets a
thousand dollar bonus like whatever the
thing is
can we turn it into something that you
and your husband can have a blast doing
you look forward to it
yeah we can totally do that
because here's what I want to do I want
to change the entire ethos around this
thing it's a gift that you are giving
yourself
and with that gift comes High
accountability so I wanted to pretend at
this point
um you are struggling with alcoholism
okay
you're an alcoholic
and it would be foolish of me to tell an
alcoholic just
drink as like a gift to yourself
not as something right that would be
insane
yeah
um
so I think for a season
it would be wise to disconnect yourself
from things
okay to have your husband change the
Amazon Prime account
to change the bank codes to take and I'm
going to be honest with you there was a
season I gave my debit card to my wife
I gave myself an allowance we did it
together but I simply could not stop
purchasing things I grew up with a lot
of money and security when I started
getting jobs
it was this compulsion I had
and I've got a bad bad problem with
authority it's tough
[Music]
and it's just it's my body goes to as
soon as it feels a boundary it feels the
need to go hit it for no reason like I
just need to see if this thing holds
hate boundaries hate them
and it wasn't until my wife said you
scare me
now I mean that was it
I don't want to scare you anymore
and that means I've got to put this
thing down because right now I don't
have control over it
see what I'm saying so it's what I'm
telling you is both and you're gonna
work on your identity you're going to
work on
what this does for us and we're gonna
work on the trust rebuild which is I'm
taking my ability to buy things away
here's what this is going to look like
in real life Megan it's gonna be the
worst
every time you feel that sense of Rage
or entitlement or I'm a grown-up and I I
want you to write that down
okay I'm feeling like I'm a child again
and then you can look at this and say
and I'm chain I'm I'm strengthening new
muscles
I'm changing my family tree here and
that tree starts one decision at a time
and it's going to be okay it's going to
be uncomfortable listen to me it's gonna
be the worst you're gonna drive up to
fill your car up with gas and you are
not gonna have cash in your wallet
you're gonna have to leave or Worse
you're gonna have to call your husband
to come get you and you are gonna be out
of your mind
then the next time you won't forget cash
right right
yeah this is the same as if somebody
cheated on somebody I always tell the
person who got cheated on
you you get to lay the ground rules for
trust rebuild you want to see all the
all the email accounts great you want to
see all the text messages every night
great
you're gonna do a spot check on the
great whatever you got to do and then
I'm gonna look at the person who did the
cheating and say are you all in
[Music]
and I'll ask you Megan are you all in
110 yes okay
from today Ford would you ever cheat
with money again
no will you commit with all of your guts
to letting go of this problem with
authority
yes money is just an extension
okay I want you to last little homework
assignment you ready
yeah tonight I want you to get a stop by
Home Depot or something on the way home
from work and I want you to buy a cinder
block just one it'd be like five or six
bucks
okay when you get home I want you to
take out a piece of duct tape or masking
tape and put it on there
and I want you to write a short little
note to your mom and dad about what they
things they used to say to you
one or two things of the way they
treated you
and then I want you to go out in the
backyard I want you to carry it around
I want you to walk around your backyard
carrying it and it's going to get real
real heavy
think about some of those things that
made you so mad in your kid
couldn't wait to get out of there
the thing your mom said at your wedding
the thing your dad did right before you
got to get all that stuff yeah and when
you can't carry that brick anymore
I want you to go to the corner of your
backyard
and just set it down
when you set it down I want you to tear
that piece of tape off and you want you
to look at that thing and say I'm not
picking you up again I'm done with those
old stories I'm writing new ones well
okay okay and every time it sounds
simple but every time you start to pick
something up you can think you'll have a
you'll have a moment kind of like a
funeral you'll be able to point to your
backyard and say nope I set this one
down my dad doesn't get a vote anymore
my mom doesn't get a vote anymore nobody
gets a vote anymore except me and my
husband moving forward and your friends
are going to tell you oh my gosh he took
away your debit card he's the worst he
no no no no I I set it down I gave it up
because I'm building new muscles now I'm
working on new things
I don't shop online anymore because my
marriage is more important than that
than my convenience
my husband does the shopping now
because he loves our marriage more than
video game time
whatever y'all got to do to make it work
let's change let's set down that stuff
you've been carrying for so long stop
let's just stop caring
let's build something entirely new
something entirely new